bonjour josé spinoza merci de répondre à
nos questions ce matin sur l' art et
france 6000 manifestants hier selon les
chiffres des autorités contre 281 2000
il y a deux ans le 17 novembre 2018
quel bilan ce que vous faites de la
journée d'hier en terme de participation
bah écoutez je fais un bilan mitigé dans
le sens où d'un côté je trouve que c'est
très bien
la reprise appelle la continuité de
l'action mais avec une intensité un peu
plus grande que les mois dernier et de
l'autre côté
évidemment on est pas encore on n'a pas
atteint le niveau de mobilisation des
débuts et c'est bien dommage parce que
la situation politique et économique
devrait amener les gens à descendre
massivement dans la rue pour exiger leur
revendique des revendications qui tourne
autour des salaires autour de la justice
fiscale autour de la démocratie je crois
qu'il ya là encore beaucoup de travail à
faire et je pense que le 17 septembre
journée d'action syndicale pour chiffrer
aussi leur mouvement est bien verrons
beaucoup de gilet jaune se rassembler
avec eux parce que il faut aujourd'hui
et c'est là la caractéristique de la
situation d'aujourd'hui il faut le
rassemblement de tous ceux qui sont
mécontents de cette politique au leur et
qu'ils veulent qu'il y ait un changement
important dans leur vie
vous appelez à une convergence des
luttes si j'ai bien compris pour la
semaine prochaine le 17 septembre
bien évidemment je sais pas si on peut
lire paul verges en ce début août dans
tous les cas rassemblement très fort
autour des grandes revendications et
autour de l'île est aussi il faut que ce
gouvernement dégage
parce qu'il ya des morts et que ce soit
sur la crise sociale
la crise politique la crise économique
où la puisaye sanitaire ce gouvernement
tous les côtés justement par délégation
vous parlez de revendication ou est-ce
qu'elles en sont les revendications
souvient du ras-le-bol fiscal à
l'origine avec la taxe carbone en
novembre 2018 on a l'impression parfois
de ne plus vraiment comprendre quelles
sont les revendications alors quelles
sont elles je suis en train de vouloir
la chute est publiée sur le journal
télévisé
les revendications me détruire
augmentation des salaires
c'est cher aimerait bien qu'il ya un
problème salarial est déjà beaucoup
gillet jeunes vivent avec des sabres en
dessous du genou c'est quelque chose de
qui et ne peut pas soutenir
il faut donc mobiliser massivement les
minima sociaux
il faut revaloriser ce qu'ils perdent du
pouvoir d'achat en paix la notaire est
ce que vous dites ce que vous dites
c'est que c'est quand même très
politique
sachant que les gilet jaune à la base
sont un mouvement apolitique sans leader
donc là vous parler politique puis on a
vu beaucoup de leaders également cette
semaine on a vu jérôme rodriguez jean
marie bigard inda bigot comment est-ce
que vous expliquer tout cela les jeunes
sont en train de changer de politique et
d'avoir des leaders mais les gilet jaune
ceci est politisé dès le début dès le
début la ressource en 2000 est issu il
est marié il mes positions
la politique du gouvernement c'est pour
ça qu'ils connaissent à mener dans la
rue ils sont politisés il faut aller
plus loin dans la politisation voilà il
ya il ya encore un écart quand rien
gérer parce que ne peut pas avoir une
vie hors sites possibles mais il faut
une autre politique selon un sondage
ifop pour le parisien publié ce matin
seuls 10 % des français se sentent
proches du mouvement pour t'en souviens
au début de la mobilisation
près de 70% des français avaient de la
sympathie pour les gilet jaune comment
est ce que vous expliquez se déclarant
cette baisse mais je sais pas si on peut
parler de déclin ce qui est sûr c'est
vrai que les violences policières ont
amené beaucoup de gens se rétracter à se
retirer
non ils sont sur le bord mais ils sont
toujours siné continue une peut-être
même plus mécontents aujourd'hui
qu'avant parce que la situation sociale
s'est dégradée et là avec les 7,5 me
lejeune qui va arriver et qui rompt pas
d'emploi on va avoir une situation
encore plus grave
donc il faudra bien qu'ils se
manifestent et il se manifestera pas
sous la forme c'est le monde et gilet
jaune
il se manifestera sur la forme de ce que
j'avais appelé dès le début le jean est
multicolore
parce qu'il faudra que les gens viennent
manifester ce bête exige une des
revendications et ils le font
je crois d'ailleurs que c'est bien parti
parce que déjà on annonce pas mal de
secteurs qui commence à être en lui
derrière comment dernière qui lui ont
rapidement on n'a plus beaucoup de temps
josé espinosa un mot s'il vous plaît sur
sur les heures et les débordements
d'hier qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
votre position en général sur la
sécurité
ce qu'on sait qu'il ya eu un nouveau
dispositif de 25 lors d'expériences avec
des bd superviser des grenades de
désencerclement moins puissante
je pense qu'on doit bien peu encore une
fois la méthode policière et bien créer
le désordre et crée les violences et
donc c'est nécessaire comme apollo
depuis deux ans on va donc qui continue
je crois que le gouvernement n'a pas
encore bien compris ce qui était en
train de se passer dans ce pays le papa
dans tous les domaines merci jeux ds qui
nous est d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur arte france je rappelle que vous
êtes gilet jaune je me remercie